hey guys Pete here today I decided to
pick back up on a series I started a few
months ago this will be my attorney at
harrenhal part 2 video that will talk
about how and Reid ended up there in the
first place no spoilers here about
current events so if you like looking at
how the back story influences the Game
of Thrones TV show this will be right up
your alley
Plus since it's Thanksgiving time all of
those in the US should remember to give
thanks to Howland since it wasn't if it
wasn't for him none of what we know as
Game of Thrones would have turned out
the same way in part one I talked about
the tourney itself and a lot of the
underlying politics that were involved
if you haven't watched it yet I'll put a
link at the end you don't really need to
watch them in order but to recap real
quick the tourney at Harrenhal was a
grand event that drew people from all
over the Seven Kingdoms to compete for
tournament prizes that were much larger
than normal
Aerys the second Targaryen was king at
the time and was on the verge of being
completely insane his heir Prince
Rhaegar won the tournament and his
decision - namely on a stark queen of
love and beauty led to the series of
events that would see Westeros plunge
into the war of the sir no matter how
you look at it the tourney at Harrenhal
was the beginning of the end for the
Targaryen reign of course there were
other things going on which might have
seen this happen anyways but in the end
this is the event that started things in
motion
if the tourney is the event and Howland
Reed is the person you may be thinking
wait don't you mean Lyanna Stark is the
person after all she was the person who
was crowned the queen of love and beauty
but no actually I think Alan and his
present there is more important after
all if he didn't attend the she wouldn't
have had to defend him as her father's
bannermen in part three we'll talk about
Leona and Rhaegar but in this video
we'll focus on how Howland Reed who
we've only seen briefly in the show and
the Tower of joy flashbacks in which by
the way he saved the young Ned starts
life if Howland didn't kill Sir Arthur
Dayne Sir Arthur Dayne would have killed
met if he killed Ned then there would be
no Sansa Arya bran or Rickon and of
course a young Jon Snow would not have
gone to
winterfell to be raised by Ned so you
can see this little talked about
character in the show is pretty crucial
to pretty much everything we've seen go
down one of the reasons I decided to
make this video now is because I read an
interesting take on the chapter where
Mira tells bran the story which was
written by reddit user Tana for it's
framed a little differently than what
I've long thought about Holland's
importance but it touches on the same
points more or less after I read that
which I'll put a link to in the
description
Howland an attorney kept popping up in
my head Mira tells bran that Holland was
a curious lad that was small like all
cranek men but brave and smart and
strong too he grew up doing normal
things like fishing and hunting and
climbing trees but also learned all the
magics of their people he could breathe
mud and run on leaves and change earth
to water and water to earth with no more
than a whisper were he could talk to
trees and we words and make castles
appear and disappear this is an
impressive group of skills with his
ability to talk to trees as being the
one that stands out most to me the
children of the forest can also talk to
trees and bran Stark is learning how to
do this with the help of the three-eyed
crow Mira continues the lad knew the
magics of the crannies but he wanted
more our people seldom travel far from
home you know we're a small folk and our
way seemed queer to some so the big
people do not always treat us kindly but
this lad was bolder than most and one
day when he had grown to manhood he
decided to leave the crags and visit the
Isle of faces and she tells the story
bran is shocked by this and says that no
one visits the Isle of faces he then
asked Mira of Holland met the green men
to this she says yes but doesn't get
into it because she says it's another
story for another time hopefully this is
a story that we'll get to hear later and
if not from mirror hearing it from Howe
and himself would be pretty awesome Tana
Ferg mentions in his reddit posts that
he feels certain that we'll hear about
it from howling in the winds of winter
which is an idea that I wholeheartedly
support after being at the Isle of faces
for season which remember is not a
regular three-month period like our
seasons Mira tells us
that palin heard the wide world calling
him and knew the time had come to leave
he said his farewells and paddled off
towards the shore from there howling
decides to stop at Harrenhal for the
tourney to take in the spectacle of the
whole thing
not long after arriving he's jumped by
three Squires who were likely around 15
years old but much bigger than Permira
they saw this as their world and the
little frog eater didn't belong in it
they basically knocked the spear out of
his hands knocked him down and started
pummeling him until lianna start saw
what was going on the Starks are the
reeds leaves Lords so she jumped in
saying the Squires needed to leave her
father's man alone
she basically chased them away then took
Alan back to her tent to dress his
wounds while there Helen met her three
brothers that are described as the wild
one which is Brandon the quiet one which
is Eddard or Ned and the young one
benjin Liana tells Howland of a feast
that night to open a tourney and she
insisted he should attend
she said he was of high birth and with
as much right to a place on the bench as
any other man he mentioned she's hard to
disagree with and then he borrows some
clothes from benjin and agrees to go
that night he ate and drank with his
fellow Northman Prince Rhaegar sang a
song so sad that it brought lianna to
tears
Lord Robert Baratheon the future king
bested the knight of skulls and kisses
in a drinking contest
helen recalls a beautiful woman with
dancing purple eyes ashara dayne dancing
with a member of the Kingsguard and
several other men the list of her
dancing partners is Sir Barristan Selmy
Prince Oberyn Martell Lord Jon
connington and Ned Stark had the last
dance it's worth noting that Ned was too
shy to ask her himself so Brandon had to
ask her to dance with his brother man
King Aerys shows up at the event even
though he hadn't left the red key for
years check out the part one video of
the series for more info on that he made
sir Jaime Lannister kneel before him to
swear the oath of the Kingsguard Jaime
was only 15 at that time
but was well admired for his courage
gallantry and skill with the sword well
all of that stuff was true the King
almost certainly added him to his
Kingsguard to take his hand Tywin
Lannister's air away from after the
other' ascent Jaime back to King's
Landing to watch over his wife which
effectively robbed him of his shot at
glory in the tournament while the party
was raging Howland spotted the three
Squires who roughed him up attending
their Knights Liana saw them too and
pointed them out to her brothers benjin
told Howland he could probably put some
armor together and get him a horse if he
wanted to try to take them on in the
tournament but Helen passes on this
since he doesn't really have any skills
that translate to jousting and he fears
will just get beaten and beyond that
he's afraid he'll completely embarrass
himself and be made to look like a fool
Eddard offers him a place in his tent to
sleep for the night
the part that's always stood out to me
after reading it a few times is what
Howland does next before going to sleep
in Ned's tent he goes to a lake shore
and says a prayer to the old gods he
looks across the water to where the Isle
of faces is to do this then in something
that looks like a direct response the
next day his prayers are basically
answered the three Knights who Squires a
tactile and advanced in the tourney but
late in the afternoon as the shadows
grew long a mystery Knight appeared in
the list if you're not familiar with the
idea of mystery nice they're actually a
bit more common than you might think
different people might enter different
tournaments well in disguise I guess
would be the best way to describe it for
a number of different reasons so
someone's showing up and taking people
on without anybody knowing who they are
isn't that completely out of the
question this mystery Knight had a
shield that was painted with a heart
tree of the old gods a white weirwood
with a laughing red face they were all
so short and clad in ill-fitting armor
that was cobbled together from different
suits the mystery Knight dipped his
Lance before the king and rode to the
end of the
lists where the five champions held
their pavilions predictably
they challenged the three knight whose
Squires had attacked Talent
whoever the mystery knight was the old
gods gave strength to his arm all three
Knights fell before the champion was
soon called when the fallen foes sought
to ransom their horses in armor the
knight of the Laughing trees voice
boomed through his helm and told them
teacher Squires honor that shall be
ransom enough once the defeated Knights
chastised their Squires sharply their
horses and armor turned and so basically
the old gods delivered a champion for
howling to answer his prayers from the
night before in his essay on the chapter
Jennifer goes into some ideas about
Knights and knighthood which are
interesting and you should read them but
that's his take which isn't really
essential to my thoughts on this whole
ordeal what I find interesting about
Howland as a character is that one day
he up and decides to further his magical
abilities by going somewhere that people
just don't really go to now I'm not
gonna get too much into the Isle of
faces since I'm planning on doing a
video about that all by itself but
basically that it's this island that's
right in the middle of things but no one
ever goes there there's plenty of
legends and stories of people trying to
reach the island and something happening
so that don't actually make it ashore
but really the only thing we know about
it for certain is this is where the
children of the forest and the first men
made their pact all that time ago so
Howland wakes up one day and decides
he's gonna go there he has no problem
getting there and then after staying
there through the end of the season he
decides to go to the biggest tourney
that has ever happened in the Seven
Kingdoms now that's not all that
surprising considering the scale but
what is surprising is that winner didn't
actually end right then this is known as
the year the fall spring because a fall
spring popped up but then after a while
everything just went back to winter so
he gets there and this happens and he
meets Liana and the Starks and then that
all leads to this crazy mystery Knight
showing up and from there we all know
what happens as far as Liana and Rhaegar
are concerned like I said I'm gonna get
way more into that in part three so
basically Howland shows up [ __ ] gets all
messed up
and then at the end a giant war breaks
out like it doesn't break out that day
but it breaks out pretty shortly after
the events of this tour knee and you
could also think about the idea that
think it you know king aerys coming may
have already foiled a plot that Rhaegar
was planning to put together
that's not important here at all but
just you know it there was a lot of
stuff going on leading up to this
tournament like I said I went over in
part one so for a long time people have
thought that Howland's major role in
this story is to be there later to
verify John's parentage I think he may
play a part in that most likely he will
even in the show I think that but before
we even get to that he's already played
a huge role in the way things played out
in the story thus far so that's the long
and the short of what we actually know
Palin went there he met the Starks and
because he was attacked a bunch of
events were set in motion that ended up
rearranging everything in the Seven
Kingdoms within a couple of years so the
speculation part and what I've always
thought that was interesting to think
about at least is if he could talk to
trees even before he went to the owl was
he guided to go there and then was he
also later guided to go to Harrenhal
we've seen this happen we've seen bran
have dreams where the Bloodraven has
sent him north of the wall and he's
accompanied by Helen reads two children
one of which is a green seer who
basically got the idea through his green
dreams but what goes beyond that and I
think that's a thing that a lot of
people have obviously thought but what
goes beyond that is is when he had when
he goes and he has his prayer was Liana
then guided to stick up for it if you're
wondering like how that would work like
how the children or the old gods knew
about the tourney it happens that
Harrenhal has a heart tree and it has a
godswood that covers about 20 acres so
it's definitely possible that they knew
that this was all going down and that's
how Allen ended up there in the first
place now there's no really way to
confirm any of that stuff but
it is interesting that we now see brand
on the similar type of journey that has
implications in a conflict that is
pretty freakin important as far as
everyone in Westeros is concern so what
I asked you guys is what would this
meeting for the children of the forest
and their influence on events in the
Seven Kingdoms we know that they were
once involved in a great war against man
and they pretty much wanted to wipe them
out but have they also been pulling the
strings here and there to pit men
against themselves whenever they see an
opportunity let me know what you guys
think and don't forget to like the video
do you think we'll see how and again if
so what kind of role do you see him
playing in the future of the series and
this could be the book or the TV show if
you haven't read the books and wondering
where Howland's been all this time so
has everyone else he's basically been a
mysterious character that everyone sort
of assumes will eventually pop back up
what are your thoughts on the children
are they political players in the Seven
Kingdoms that no one really realizes and
what do you think we're gonna see from
brand now that he can talk to the trees
as well I am having a book giveaway
right now so subscribe if you want to
enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video or any of the other ones where I
mentioned this particular giveaway when
I hit 28,000 subscribers I'll be giving
one lucky commenter a copy of the new
20th anniversary edition of a game of
Thrones by George RR martin Utley
subscribe and leave a comment for your
chance to win I will be adding a part
three to this series I'm not sure
exactly where that's gonna fit into my
schedule of videos but definitely check
back for that in the future thanks for
watching
I'll talk to you soon